people in the town of ottoman on head to
church early on Sunday mornings it's
just six o'clock united in their
Catholic faith
and in their opposition to a
controversial construction project
nearby it's been part of our advocacy to
fight coal plants because it's harmful
to people harmful to environment
coal is dirty we just want to to protect
our people and this is in keeping with
the social teachings of the church that
teaches us to care for the earth and
care for for those who are in the
margins of society after mass the
congregation head to the site of a
planned coal-fired power plant to check
if construction has already begun they
keep a detailed record of developments
[Music]
father Nowell says contractors have
already started to clear the area of
trees someday this woman fears the plant
will poison the local drinking water you
are joining the global movement to
divest from fossil fuels and that's a
macro level approach so not just a micro
that the town we are protecting our
people they are joining the much larger
picture for the protection of our common
home the Philippines has rapid
population growth 12 million people live
in Metro Manila alone and the power grid
is in urgent need of modernization
electricity is expensive and the plants
generate a lot of pollution Joanne Ayala
is head of sustainable energy finance at
a bank and says there are major business
opportunities in the sector turn your
business green to balloon so you don't
just do green to be happy to feel good
about what you do to do good for the
environment make money out of it 2/3 of
the Philippines energy consumption is
actually coming from fossil fuel so in
our own little way as
here in the country what we hope to do
is to help shift that energy mix to to
cleaner energy we help make sure that
the projects are profitable and designed
in a technically viable way by providing
consultations this is one of the
projects her bankers financed to the
tune of 1 million euros just a year ago
it was a stinking open rubbish dump the
biggest landfill site in Manila
now the garbage has been covered with
earth and is used to generate
electricity
silver Navarro is an engineer and
renewable energy consultant this well is
connected down to the ground and it's
collecting the methane gas and other
gases that's being produced by the
decomposing garbage inside so we have
more than 100 of these wells drilled
around the dump site
the gas goes through a power plant where
it drives turbines Navarro checks
regularly how much electricity the gas
generates he says the garbage should
yield gas for 30 more years he provides
advice on energy projects and how to
finance them to countries across Asia
I'm looking at this in a let's say you
know longer-term way because you also
ought to invest in our future and our
future also depends on how clean our
environment will be not for only for
ourselves but also for the future
generation and making good business also
creates a good environment for
continuing what good things were
starting to do now that landfill project
may be good for the environment but it's
not so welcome for people living in the
slum nearby who have lost their source
of income they used to pick through the
garbage of things they could sell for
recycling plastic and aluminium
now children look for those items while
they're still on garbage trucks the
drivers stop for a few minutes to let
the kids climb the board and rummage
around
brian is 13 and has already been
collecting garbage for three years he
lives with his mother and five brothers
and sisters
he tells us he knows how to read and
write and is proud of that that above
all I'm a nurse and I work every day
from 7:00 in the morning until 6:00 in
the evening I earn about 200 pesos a day
and read business that's equivalent to
about 3 euros when he grows up he wants
to work on a garbage truck
in our Timon on the campaigners are
hoping they can still prevent the
construction of the coal plant there's
one more permit the authorities have yet
to issue father Noel and his
congregation are determined to do their
part for the environment
we installed two sets of solar panels
one in the rectory and out there for our
church our main goal is to provide cheap
electricity for the church and at the
same time this is the good way of
showing to the whole world that we can
make use of renewable energy source and
once we we have shown that the viability
we can gradually switch from the dirty
energy source to the renewable one by
next year the entire roof of the church
complex is said to be covered in
photovoltaic panels in addition to their
efforts to block fossil fuels and
increase environmental awareness the
congregation are making a positive
contribution of their own by switching
to solar
you